orhan premiers foyers d'éclosion de la
maladie ressemble à une ville déserte
c'est aussi le cas dans l'ensemble de la
province centrale du hubei au total 56
millions de chinois sont confinés à leur
milieu
empêché de se déplacer les autorités
chinoises assure être prêt à prendre
toutes les mesures d'urgence pour
prévenir la propagation du virus
le directeur de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé et le président chinois ont
convenu qu'une délégation d'experts
internationaux se rendent en chine pour
apporter une réponse mondiale à
l'épidémie ailleurs les autorités
politiques et sanitaires s'organise le
japon a commencé à envoyer des avions
pour rapatrier ses ressortissants encore
réduit de moitié les vols en provenance
de chine continentale et ferme six de
ses 14 points de passage frontaliers
les etats unis annoncent eux qu'il
planche sur la mise au point de vaccins
le plus rapidement possible alors que le
rapatriement de leurs citoyens se fera
dans les prochains jours même chose en
europe
un premier cas d'infection secondaire
c'est à dire chez une personne qui n'a
pas visité la chine a été identifiée en
allemagne
l'europe s'apprête à envoyer des avions
pour rapatrier ses ressortissants
la france a maintenant quatre cas de
personnes contaminées sur son sol entre
500 et 1000 français se trouvent
actuellement dans la zone touchée par le
virus
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir identifier
sur place il y à des personnes malades
pour qu'elle fasse l'objet d'une prise
en charge particulière et d'un transport
particulier et que nous ne mélangeons
pas des personnes malades et des
personnes sans symptômes
après ceux de toronto un premier cas a
été identifié à vancouver principale
porte d'entrée de la communauté chinoise
au canada
le transporteur canadien annonce
l'annulation de certaines ses vols vers
la chine au cours des dernières heures
250 canadiens ont contacté leurs
services consulaires en chine plus de la
moitié d'entre eux ont demandé à être
rapatriées réponse officielle reste
vague pour le moment qu'on est en train
de considérer les différentes options
pour offrir les services consulaires
dont les canadiens présentement besoin
on est en train de consulter on regarde
toutes les options c'est la
recommandation officielle du
gouvernement du québec et de santé
canada et d'affaires mondial canada 9e
n'est pas en chine tant que l' alerte
n'est pas relevé pour nous c'est
extrêmement garde ça veut dire que
l'année 2020 commence avec un
ralentissement important de nos
activités
pékin a décidé de prolonger les longs
congés du nouvel an espérant réduire les
déplacements et les risques d'infection
le début du semestre scolaire a été
reportée
pendant ce temps à bourg ain la
situation s'avère parfois chaotique
les patients doivent attendre des heures
avant de voir un médecin
les autorités ont réagi la construction
de deux hôpitaux pouvant accueillir
chacun plus de 1000 lits doit être
achevée d'ici 15 jours et si sylvain
desjardins radio canada montréal